photography is bigger than just
images it's bigger than a career
[Music]
it's a process of discovery both
external
and internal i want to invite you
into my world of photography things
aren't that interesting for me
unless the stakes are very high we're
going to scramble to the top top top
with photography you're telling a
narrative there's depth behind
it one image to tell this whole story
think about how they look visually what
your compositions look like
the way i'm shooting this i'm like
underexposing quite a bit i know that
i'm gonna pull up the shadows in post
all of a sudden it changes the entire
dynamic of the image
it really begins before you even pick up
a camera
when you're passionate about something
you know something deeply
it takes it should be a calling
oh god
[Music]
the best types of shoots are the ones
where you're having fun
i think i'm gonna go a little lower i
want him higher in the horizon line
you build incredible relationships some
images aren't possible unless you have
that relationship
that's great conrad
what i've realized over the years is
there's always going to be the next big
thing
appreciate being in the moment with what
you're doing
photography is such a cool vehicle to
give you access to the world
look at where the bar has been set
before
and setting higher ask yourself what
you're willing to do to get there
[Music]
i'm jimmy chin and this is my master
[Music]
class
you